her comedy combines her southern charm
and hilarious storytelling about her own
life into an act that keeps coming back
for more and her 100 city big panty tour
hits las vegas tonight at the encore
theater at the win mercedes sat down
with the hilarious leanne morgan
hey leanne
hello
oh it is so good to have you all
well you don't thank you for having me
you beauty oh
i look like i'm sick with the flu i want
to be pretty for y'all
you look beautiful are you kidding me
that red the red that please are you
gonna wear red on your show when you are
at the encore theater in vegas i don't
know yet i know what should i wear what
should i wear it's vegas um
i'm so excited i'm scared you know i'm
on 100 city tour and it's funny to me
nobody cares until i'm going to vegas
and then all my friends and family are
like looking for flights and
buying new outfits and everybody's so
excited and i mean i'm everywhere i'm
all over the united states i don't care
they just want to come to find us we
can't wait to have you and the encore
theater at the wind which is where
you're going to be performing
that is seriously top-notch venue one of
the nicest places in town i am so pumped
for it and i'm and you know i'm pumped
at every i go out every weekend and do
shows and i'm i was just in cedar rapids
in wichita kansas and then i'll be in
memphis and then i'm going to
oh i don't know i'm all over but
something about this it's just like i
feel electric here in knoxville
tennessee
in my children's playroom that i've made
into an office i can feel the
electricity
and everybody is so excited and i know
the wind the encore
i know i saw her was it diana rose who
was there and i thought oh my lord i
cannot let it get my head you know but i
am i'm so tickled that they're letting
me come in there if they would if they
would just let me go in there and mop
i'd be thrilled
and if people don't know it's the big
panty tour that that that's what it's
called so the big panties on the side
like and and where does that come from
pull up your big girl panties well no
not really even though i guess it's good
we all built pull up our big girl
panties but more it was this is crazy
but it was more like you know
i like big panties
and i felt like i'm at a point in my
life where
i deserve to be comfortable and have a
good time and be around fun people and
not be around
hateful people and i don't know it's
just like like a sign of relief like
big panties what are the guys what do
they have to look forward to at your
show
it's a lot of relatable stuff i know
that it is and they i see a lot of
couples going
at each other and so man
i think i explain things to these
precious men that they're confused about
i think that um they are married to
women like me i think i am married to
men like them and but it's all fun and
it's um light-hearted and we have a ball
explaining to these precious men
that's what we need more women
explaining hey man you can check out
leanne morgan the big panty tour tonight
at eight o'clock encore theater at wynn
head up to ticketmaster.com for more
information